Always remember
The universe has a way of leading into where you're supposed to be at the moment you're supposed to be there let's do this
It took me 20 years to find you
How many people can say that
You are the best-kept secret in the universe
and
I found you which makes me perfect for this job
You really think a black suit
It's going to solve all your problems
no but looks, damn good on you
We are
Recognizable only as deja vu and
dismissed just as quick a
time to prove yourself agent M we may have a problem in London
welcome to MI beam
You will be with Asian Paints one of the best ever to ever suit
Catching up on my daily meditation time for lunch. Ah thank you hungry it's 9:30 it's Tuesday's taco day
We've been compromised is every citizen of this planet at risk
If you could all just look right here just try
Gonna be fun left fun with it
There should be a big red button around here, somewhere found it
We are the men in black
Looks like a tables of 10 go I was incredible